se acerca el final del título 42 el cual
aspirará este 11 de mayo y en Estados
Unidos se preparan para la nueva etapa
buscando alternativas para aplacar el
flujo migratorio en la frontera Sur en
el caso del gobernador de Texas la
decisión pasa por robustecer la
seguridad fronteriza con la presencia de
oficiales el Estado Sureño desplegará
otros 540 guardias nacionales y
helicópteros Black Hawk para repeler a
los migrantes irregulares
Texas está haciendo más que cualquier
estado en la historia de los Estados
Unidos de América para defender nuestra
frontera esto incluye desplegar hasta
10.000 miembros de la guardia nacional y
1.200 Soldados del departamento de
seguridad pública de Texas
la contracara son las personas que
buscan pasar la frontera antes del
jueves día en el que empezará a regir el
título 8 que tiene castigos más severos
para quienes entren irregularmente a
Estados Unidos la esperanza es avanzar y
evitar la burocracia de las próximas
medidas Claro si cambian las cosas no te
iba a durar cuatro o cinco un año como
lo han hecho estos compatriotas que
vienen a traer nosotros y Entonces
nosotros No quería nada de eso para
nosotros que no no que arriesganos si
pasaban los fines si no bueno el
gobierno de Joe biden anunció que se
implementarán nuevos procedimientos para
entrar al país como la instalación de
centros de procesamiento regionales o la
ampliación del programa de reunificación
familiar con el objetivo de evitar los
viajes a lo largo del continente